[Music]
this is a story about a place very very
very far away from here
where tiny little farmers
live with their families
and small one-inch long parking dogs
and they make their cars
out of cans
[Music]
these farmers thought that there must be
a way to know why the stars are shining
and they wanted to see
and they decided to go
on a mission
[Music]
[Music]
so they decided to go for a ride
and they drove on the highway
they drove on the highway past the
armadillos like the armadillos in
switzerland and they said
it is so beautiful
[Music]
and as they drove they looked from car
to car smiling at each other as they
drove
past each other as they drove past each
other and they smiled and they said
hello farmer they said hello to each
other hello farmer
hello
[Music]
birds flying in the sky
and the farmers looked up and pointed at
the birds and said look
[ __ ]
then the birds flowed and swooped down
upon the cars in a friendly fashion
[Music]
and finally
the farmers reached a place where the
people were much much bigger than they
were
these people were actually normal size
as we know them
and they did not make their cars
out of cans but they made their cars
[Music]
and these people were giants to the
farmers
and they had some fear
but they were strong and noble these
farmers and they decided that they did
not belong here and that this was not a
good place for them
[Music]
and so they turned around and they drove
home
but they had a nice day
they had a nice day
[Music]
and the husbands and the wives smiled at
each other
and the children
played in the yard
but they still to this day
[Music]
is
[Music]
you